adam wainwright will get the start for
the cardinals this afternoon
last time out against cleveland tuesday
night the road game seven innings four
hits
and a 4-2 st louis win
and he has been awfully good here in
2021 strikeout to start this game of
kepler
120 strikeouts for adam wainwright who's
coming off an eight strikeout
performance and his win tuesday night in
cleveland as rooker smacks a line drive
base hit center field and a high sinker
with rooker teeing off a one-out single
hit the other way backing up o'neal
and he'll make the catch and that's the
innings wins don't score get a hit leave
one one-half played in st louis michael
pineda big guy six seven
280 pounds from the dominican it was a
lot of thought that uh he would be
traded during this deadline by minnesota
and the o2
on the ground right side base hit for
dylan carlson
thinking about two right there right out
of the gate good job by dylan and the
2-2 swing and a miss strike three throw
to second base is going to be
dropped by polanco
so arenado chased a low slider strikes
out swinging but stealing second base
carlson and the 1-2 pitch there it is
it's hung but popped up
back of second base polanco drifting out
to the grass in right center he's got it
and that's the inning cardinals don't
score leave a man after one no score
mitch garver leading off the second
for his last seven and a one one a line
drive left side base hit that will add
to it with a lead off single
to start the second inning that was
smoke left to bat at 108 miles an hour
and the 2-2 pitch a line drive missile
to left center field and the gap that is
down for a base hit that's going to find
the wall
garber to third base he's going to be
held by diaz that's another scorching
double from ceno and the twins are at
business second and third nobody out in
the second inning
strikes so there's your strikeout job so
one out and now first base open simmons
the batter angelton's been hot and he
loves facing the cardinals in 20 career
games against st louis he's hitting over
380. second and third one out
and the yo-1 pitch a flare into center
field that's going to land for a base
hit one run is in rounding third heading
home ceno the throw to the plate is
going to be cut off and simmons stays
hot drives in two and the twins take a
two nothing lead pineda puts it in play
arenado to second oh my goodness an
incredible double play started by nolan
orinato
who throws that ball
cardinals have a man in scoring position
for dylan carlson and the 01 pitch to
dillon
fly ball shallow left and this ball will
get down sosa was about halfway now
rounding third he will score it's a
double for dylan carlson the cardinals
are down by a run with carlson
representing the tying run here's
goldschmidt with the tying run at second
and that's a base hit into center
here comes carlson
throw to the plate cut off and paul has
just tied the game at two rbi number 56
for paul goldsmith
and the 1-2 pitch check swing he went
strike three on a slider so o'neill
strikes out but the cardinals tied up
two runs on three hits in league one
good game so far three in all tied two
two arrive set to lead things off a
swing and a fly ball center field here
comes bader on the run he dives he makes
the catch that would have been a base
hit for a rise but vader takes that hit
away with a good quick first step left
his feet made the catch and after a
short slide on the outfield grass the
2-2
swung on and missed strikeout number
three slow curve ball strikes out garber
the one-two pitch
and he struck him out
a cut fast ball over at the knees cenote
was frozen potential walk to sosa will
get wainwright to the plate with two men
aboard 3-2
bueno hitch hits sharply to third
arises
up with it but chenow can't come up with
it and a run scores and it makes it a
3-2 st louis lead
you have got to be kidding me he picked
that ball right there that is so
crazy
tried to be too careful and just didn't
get it there costly air that's his fifth
of the year no balls two strikes
line drive that's going to be fielded by
polanco on the run and retires
carson the
st louis cardinals though take a three
to two lead on the throwing error
the twins swung a deal with the
cardinals the train deadline day of
friday
giving up jay happ getting john and cam
veteran a pitcher and he will be making
his twins debut yadier molina chance to
make some history today at the plate as
he is one hit away from breaking a tie
with he and his good buddy albert pujols
on the cardinals all-time hits list
there it is a base hit into right center
he is now in fourth place all alone on
the cardinals all-time hits list hit
number 2074.
he passes albert pujols
and he is fourth all time in hits
in cardinals history yachty running
pitch gets away
o'neal will score
and it's a 4-2 cardinals lead
polanco for two trying to get something
going against wainwright and 1-1
hit high near right center field long
run carlson back and looks up going
right off the top of the fence and right
center field and the twins now trail by
one four to three no balls two strikes
on sosa
got to find a way to get edmond to third
and that's one way to do it he's running
and it's a base hit
he'll find his way to the plates on an
o2 pitch the base hit by sosa and it's
back to a two-run st louis lead adam
wainwright pitching to yachty and
pitching to him in the seventh inning
which he's gone at least seven innings
ten different times this year second
most in baseball pulls the bat out over
the plate now the pitch
a high fly ball left field lazy sunday
afternoon fly ball for tyler o'neill he
makes the catch twins don't score they
leave one as we stretch in st louis
cardinals batting leading five to three
it's giovani gallegos chevy call to the
pen after another start in which the
cardinals get seven innings from adam
wainwright the o2 pitch
three pitches and a strikeout 95 on the
gun from gallegos
polanco gets underneath it and a high
fly ball
into right center vader over to make the
catch and mundo sosa and sosa on the
first pitch a high fly ball into deep
right center
and mundo sosa
the first pitch in the bottom of the
eighth
some insurance for the cardinals
sosa his third home run and it's 6-3
into right field shallow with nobody out
carpenter trying to score cut off by
cino throw to third they got him there
out at third base dylan carlson but the
run scores and the cardinals have a
seven to three lead a sacrifice fly for
paul goldsmith ray is on for the ninth
inning in a non-save situation power
right-handed arm from the cardinal pen
swing and got him game over
cardinals win it 7-3 a 1-2-3 for alex
reyes